Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our
session on
sleep and sleep
disorders. I'm
Dr. Carl Abraham,
and today we're
going to explore how
sleep works, why it
matters, and what
happens when it
goes wrong. Think of
this as your foundation
for understanding
one of the most
essential yet
often overlooked
physiologic processes.
I don't know about
any of you. It's also
a subject that's very
dear to my heart.
We're going to cover
the basics of sleep
physiology, then how
to recognize and manage
common sleep disorders,
including when
to order a polysomnogram
and when to
involve a specialist.
And then we'll finish
by talking about sleep
wellness and why it's
critical for both
patient safety and
your own performance
as a future physician.
I've included some
connections to other
lectures on this
slide, as well as
QR codes that pointed
to the scholar
Rx Bricks for,
on the top, sleep
physiology and underneath
sleep disorders.
We're going to start
with sleep physiology
in order to understand
what is healthy
before we take a look
at what is a disorder.
So, as you know, we
assess sleep health in
every patient as part
of the social history.
Sleep needs change
dramatically
across the lifespan.
Newborns may sleep
up to 20 hours a day.
Children and
adolescents still
require much more
sleep than adults.
Most adults need
somewhere between
seven to nine
hours every night.
There are cultural and
regional differences,
for example,
siestas, that still
result in normal
amounts of sleep. and as
we age, especially
as we become elderly,
we tend to go to
sleep earlier.
Our sleep-wake
cycle is governed by
circlinging rhythms.
These are internal
biological clocks present
in almost all living
organisms. Without
sunlight or other
external clues, the
human natural rhythm
actually runs closer
to 25 hours. These
rhythms shape our
physical, mental, and
behavioral patterns
throughout the day.
If it isn't obvious,
sleep is a repeating
cyclical behavior
that follows the
circadian or 24-hour
rhythm. The processes
that maintain homeostasis
differ between
wakefulness and
sleep. For example,
wakefulness is marked
by feeding while
sleeping is a fasting
state. As you can
see on this slide,
many metabolic and
cannabolic processes
are influenced by these
states. For example,
muscle glycolysis
and cortisol, bile
acid, and insulin
secretion occur more
during the waking state,
while melatonin,
growth hormone, and
leptin secretion, and
oxidative metabolism
in muscle primarily
occurs during sleep.
Importantly, animal
models have shown
that CNS neurotoxins
such as amyloid,
beta, and tau
are cleared more
efficiently during
sleep. In addition,
although they are
poorly understood,
dreams may function
to reduce stress
and sleep is important
in consolidating
memory, a fact
you can use to
improve the efficiency
of studying.
So the bottom
line, sleep is far
more than just
rest for the body.
And key tool
in evaluating
sleep disorders is
the polysomnogram
or overnight sleep study.
It records brain
waves, eye movements,
muscle tone, heart
rhythm, breathing
patterns, oxygen levels,
and limb movements.
This comprehensive
monitoring makes it
the gold standard for
diagnosing conditions
such as sleep
apnea, narcolepsy,
parasomnias, and the
rest of Flegge syndrome,
all of which we'll
talk about later.
The picture on the
top right shows lead
placement for an
electroencephalogram.
These leads then
feed into a computer,
previously onto
a piece of paper,
sort of like a
lie detector test,
that transcribed the
electrical activity
in various places
in the brain.
The result are the
patterns to the right,
which show the
different types of waves
seen in the different
stages of sleep.
You can also see that
as we fall into deeper
and deeper sleep,
the cycles of brain
electrical activity slow.
beta waves are rapid
frequency waves that
are present while awake
and active alpha waves
and at rest theta
waves are present at
early stages of sleep
and delta waves the
slowest waves during deep
sleep not shown is the
brain activity during
REM or REM which is
erratic alternating
between slow and fast
frequency waves the
picture on the bottom is
an example of one person
who underwent a sleep
study. One of the
misunderstandings of the
stages of sleep is
that we cycle through
the stages in order and
then enter REM and then
move back through
the stages in reverse
order. That's actually
not true. As you can
see, this particular
patient enters REM sleep
later in the night
without entering the
deepest stages of sleep,
which is typical. The
time the patient goes
to bed until the patient
falls asleep is called
the sleep latency.
In this patient, it's
about 30 minutes. The
time from the beginning
of sleep until the
first REM sleep is
called the REM latency.
Sleep architecture
refers to the
structure of sleep
across the night.
The American Academy
of Sleep defines
wakefulness and
the stages of sleep
N1, N2, N3, and
REM based on the
distinct EEG
patterns and physical
characteristics of
each of these states.
Wakefulness, or stage W,
here refers to awake
at breast. Alpha waves
on EEG are 9 to 11
hertz, and there is
very little muscle
tone except for in the
face. As we drift
toward sleep, stage N1,
EEG slows,
eyelids droop, and
pupils constrict,
and the eyes may rove
from side to side.
Stage N2 is
characterized by slower
waves overall, but
also sleek spindles.
These are faster
waves detected
at the bitemporal reads.
Delta waves are
characteristic
of deepest sleep.
REM EEG patterns are
erratic, and there
is a further decrease
in muscle tone
except for the
extraocular muscles,
resulting in bursts of
rapid eye movements.
Physiologically,
non-REM and REM sleep
differ in important
ways. Non-REM is
characterized by stable vital
signs and increased
parasympathetic tone.
Dreams occur in non
-REM sleep, but they are
much less vivid and
intense compared to
the dreaming that
characterizes REM sleep.
REM brings bursts of
autonomic activity,
irregular heart
rhythm, decreased
thermoregulation,
vivid dreaming,
and near-complete
muscle paralysis,
except for the
extraocular movements.
Now that we've covered
normal sleep, let's
look at sleep disorders,
conditions that
disrupt sleep quality,
timing, or physiology.
has fallen to two broad
categories, disomnias
and parasomnias.
Disomnias are disorders
of sleep-wake time
and or quality, while
parasomnias are physical
behaviors such as
sleepwalking or experiences
like sleep terrors that
occur during or around
the time of sleep.
Disomnias can also
be broken down
into two categories,
primary or
extrinsic, and
secondary or extrinsic.
Primary dysomnias
include primary
insomnia, which
we'll talk about in a
minute, sleep-related
movement disorders,
such as restless
leg syndrome, or
central disorders
of hypersomnolence,
for example, narcolepsy.
Secondary or extrinsic
dysomnias include
secondary insomnia,
in other words, the
insomnia that's caused
by mostly psychiatric
disorders or other
things, but again we'll
talk about that again
in the next few slides,
circadian sleep
rhythm disorders, for
example jet lag, or
other medical illnesses
that specifically cause
trouble sleeping. A
very common one is
obstructive sleep apnea,
but any other illness
that affects sleep
can be a secondary
cause of insomnia. For
example, congestive
heart failure that
causes frequent paroxysmal
nocturnal dyspnea,
nocturnal reflux
esophagitis, or even
acute illnesses such
as an infection.
It occurs episodically
in about 95% of adults
at some point, but
it's chronic in only
about 10% adults.
Patients complain of not
being able to fall asleep,
daytime sleepiness,
and or fatigue or not
having enough energy.
Primary insomnia, in
other words, insomnia
for which no secondary
cause is found,
makes up only about
10% of those with
insomnia. One pattern
of primary insomnia
that has been noted
is that which occurs
after a stressful
period has resolved. The
good news for these
cases is that most
of the time this
resolves spontaneously.
About 90% of those
with insomnia have
secondary insomnia.
About 50% of these
cases are due to a
psychiatric condition
such as depression,
anxiety, mania, PTSD,
ADHD, or OCD.
Medications that may
cause secondary insomnia
include stimulants,
for example,
caffeine, nicotine,
amphetamines, and *******,
depressants such as
opiates, alcohol,
barbiturates, and
benzodiazepines,
hallucinogens like
phancyclidine,
***, *********, and
MDMA, or diuretics that
are prescribed to
the patient close to
bedtime so that they are
going to the bathroom
repeatedly at night,
acute and chronic
medical conditions
such as COPD, systolic
heart failure, BPH, acute
gastroenterocolitis,
or even post-surgical
pain can stop
people from having a
good night's sleep.
Treatment of insomnia
includes treating
underlying conditions or
discontinuing substances
or medications that
promote insomnia
for those with secondary
insomnia, regular
exercise and a nutritious
diet, sleep hygiene,
which we'll talk
about in a minute, and
non-benzodiazepine
hypnotics, such as Zolpidem,
Xaloplon, and Esopoclon.
These medications
can be remembered
by the mnemonic ZZZ.
For insomnia, should
be sleep hygiene,
which we'll talk about
on the next slide.
Pharmacologic
treatment should start
with the ZZZ, non
-benzodiazepine
hypnotics, or
melatonin receptor
agonists. If these
don't work, then
benzodiazepines can
be tried. However,
there are disadvantages
to benzodiazepines.
They disrupt the
sleep cycle and
specifically prevent
deep sleep. They may be
addictive and they
are associated with
falls that lead to
trauma in the elderly.
If benzodiazepines
don't work, then
antipsychotics, antidepressants,
and antihistamines
can be tried. These
are last resorts
due to very high
side effect profiles.
If the treatment
scheme is different
than this for specific
sleep disorders,
I'll mention it when
we talk about them.
The attempted prior
to pharmacologic
therapy and
pharmacologic therapy
should not be given
without attention
to sleep hygiene
because of its influence
on sleep. What
is sleep hygiene?
The patient should
wake up in the
morning and go to
sleep at night about
the same time every
day. They should
avoid late-day
caffeine, alcohol, large
meals, and screens
close to bedtime.
And sleep should happen
in a quiet, dark,
stress, phone, and
pet-free environment.
Many of us don't
follow this regimen,
but research has
shown that this is how
to get a good night's
sleep most nights.
Let's start talking
about specific sleep
disorders Although
restless leg syndrome is
considered a sleep
movement disorder The
patient's symptoms occur
while awake and actually
prevent sleep The
patient experiences leg
burning, itching,
or tingling that is
relieved by movement It
occurs in about 5-15% of
the population at
some time during their
life The cause is
unknown in most cases but
in a few, it may be
secondary to pregnancy,
iron deficiency,
peripheral neuropathy,
chronic kidney
disease, or ADHD.
Importantly,
restless leg syndrome
is not the presenting
symptom in any of
these except for iron
deficiency. So any
patient with restless leg
syndrome should have
iron studies and iron
deficiency should be
treated if present.
Specific treatment
for restless
leg syndrome
is pregabalin,
dopamine agonists,
and gampapentin.
The restless leg
syndrome that
is associated
with pregnancy
usually resolves
after delivery.
The circadian rhythm
sleep-wake disorders
are those which
disrupt sleep timing.
For example, the most
common is probably
jet lag, the
treatment of which is
usually melatonin,
although a recent study
suggested that if one
can stay awake while
the sun is up at
your destination and
wait to go to sleep
when the sun goes
down, the severity of
jet lag is reduced.
Uncommon causes
of circadian
rhythm sleep-wake
disorders include
delayed sleep
phase disorder.
People with this
go to bed and
wake up later than
the usual times.
It may occur in
those who are blind
and those who do
night shift work.
Advanced sleep
phase disorder is
similar, but
instead the patient
goes to bed and
wakes up early.
Treatment for
these include
sleek hygiene,
light therapy, and
melatonin
receptor agonists.
The prototypical
central disorder of
hypersomnolence is narcolepsy.
Think of narcolepsy
as REM intrusion into
wakefulness. There
is sleep paralysis
or the inability to
talk or move on awakening
or falling asleep.
Hypnopopic and hypnagogic
hallucinations are
those that occur when
you wake or fall asleep,
respectively. They
may occur in those
without narcolepsy, but
are much more frequent
in those with it.
Those with narcolepsy
may also have cataplexy
after experiencing
strong emotions that
can result in sometimes
significant trauma.
Patients complain of
daytime sleepiness.
Onset is usually in
young adults and the
condition is not
progressive. It occurs
in less than 0.2% of
the U.S. population
with peaks at 15
and 35 years of age.
90% of those have
an HLA-DQB1-0602
allele, which is
present much less
commonly in those
without narcolepsy.
Studies have shown
that patients may
have decreased
orexin production.
Onset may follow a
viral or bacterial
infection. The
diagnosis is made
by polysomnogram,
which shows rapid
sleep onset,
short REM latency.
Shorter REM latency
is associated
with more severe disease.
Treatment is sleep
hygiene and stimulants,
such as those
was listed on the
slide. Prognosis is
usually excellent
with treatment.
Patients with narcolepsy
commonly require
concomitment
treatment for depression
and or anxiety.
Obstructive sleep apnea
is a sleep-related
breathing disorder
caused by mechanical
obstruction of excess
soft tissue that
results in a rapid
repetitive airway
collapse, in other
words, snoring, and
hypoxygenation due to
short apneic episodes.
Risk factors include
increased age, obesity,
large tonsils
or a large neck,
polycystic ovary
disease, hypothyroidism,
genetic predisposition,
systolic heart failure,
chronic kidney failure,
alcohol use, smoking,
and the male gender.
Prevalence is
about 32% in U.S.
adults greater
than 20 years old.
Most are male. The
storing results
in the inability
to reach deep
sleep and is often
brought to medical
attention by the
sleep partner.
Diagnosis is by
polysomnogram.
Treatment is continuous
positive airway
pressure, which is shown
in the picture at right.
A tightly fitting
mask delivers air at
increased pressure that
keeps the airways open
and prevents the
collapse of soft tissue.
Patients may require a
uvulopoadopharyngeoplasty
that repositions
or resex the uvula,
resex the tussles,
and enlarges the
pharynx, but this
is rarely done.
So let's leave the
disomnias and talk about
parasomnias. Remember
the parasomnias
are behaviors or
experiences that occur
during sleep. We'll talk
about the most common
and there are many
others. The parasomnias
are also categorized
by which stage of
sleep in which they
occur. The first
parasomnia we'll talk
about, sleep terrors,
occurs in stage N3.
About 1% of children
will have them. The
child wakes at night
scared, upset, maybe
yelling, maybe panicking,
and is completely
inconsolable. There
may be associated
autonomic sympathetic
activation with
tachycardia, tachypnea, and
diaphoresis. The
child eventually calms
down, goes back to
sleep, and in the morning
has no recollection
that this occurred.
Prognosis is excellent
with the sleep
terrors eventually
resolving spontaneously.
Another parasomnia,
sleepwalking or somnambulism
also occurs in stage
N3. Despite being
asleep, the person
appears awake and
performs activities
such as walking, working
in the kitchen, or
many other types of
activities and has no
memory of the event the
next morning. This
occurs in up to 30% of
the U.S. population as
a single non-repeating
event, but chronic
sleepwalking may affect
up to 2% of the adult
population. Treatment
is difficult and
centers around keeping
the patient safe,
since some of the
activities such as walking
out of the house or
working in the kitchen
are dangerous. It
usually resolves
spontaneously in children.
If it doesn't in
adults, underlying
medical or psychological
conditions that are
the root of the
behavior should be
treated, and some
patients are treated with
benzodiazepines with
varying success.
The last parasomnia
we'll talk about
is REM sleep
behavior disorder.
This occurs in adults
who yell, kick,
punch, grab, jump, or
perform other aggressive
or violent behaviors
while asleep.
It usually occurs
in older persons
who remember dreams
that explain their
behavior, but they
don't remember
performing the behavior
while sleeping.
Polysomnobram
shows REM sleep
despite the
lack of atonia.
Treatment is
melatonin or low
-dose clonazepam.
Very importantly,
brainstem histology
at autoxy has shown
Lewy bodies that
are also seen in
Parkinson's,
multisystem atrophy, and
Lewy body dementia,
and some feel that
REM sleep behavior
disorder is an early
manifestation of
these conditions.
We've talked about
sleep physiology and
sleep disorders. Now
let's apply these
concepts in a way
that highlights the
importance of sleep
wellness to a subject
that we as students
of medicine should be
at the top of our
minds, patient safety.
Before we talk
about patient safety
specifically, let's clear
up some myths and define
the negative health
outcomes of sleep
deprivation. There is a
very rare prion disease
called fatal familial
insomnia that results
in progressive insomnia
and eventual death
in all patients. This
suggests that the
total lack of sleep
can be deadly. However,
based on anecdotal
evidence of people who
have tried to break the
Guinness Book Record
for longest time awake,
we do know some of the
effects of sleep
deprivation and true
fatalities from sleep
deprivation are exceedingly
rare. A few days
without sleep results in
progressive, slowed, and
altered cognition and
motor control.
This is followed by
hallucinations,
paranoia, memory
loss, and eventually
psychosis in some
persons who are sleep
-deprived for long periods.
The Guinness record
for the longest time
awake is 18 days, 21
hours and 40 minutes.
If I remember correctly,
this particular person
had a few symptoms
of sleep deprivation.
However, there have been
enough people trying
for the record who
have had severe symptoms
after sleep deprivation,
some possibly
permanent, that Guinness
no longer monitors or
reports sleep deprivation
records due to the
negative health effects.
And we all know that
sleep deprivation does
increase the risk of
falling asleep at the
wheel and serious motor
vehicle accidents.
One of the most sleep
-deprived population is
house staff, medical,
surgical, psychiatry,
family practice, and
OB residents who are
sometimes up for 24 or
36 hours more at a time.
They make an excellent
study population.
The first study looked
at house staff who are
on call every fourth
night. 44% reported
falling asleep at a
stoplight, 49% fell asleep
at the wheel, and 23
% while the car was in
motion. 90% of these
events occurred post
-call. The second study
shows being sleep-deprived
increases the risk
of near-misses and
accidents in driving
simulations, and the third
shows subjects
performed worse in every
measure of cognitive
function when tested even
with moderate sleep
deprivation and that
prolonged periods of
sleep deprivation for
example four to five
hours of sleep nightly had
a cumulative effect
resulting in increasing
cognitive impairment
not only that but when
you don't get enough
sleep judgment is impaired
and the result is
poor decisions. Sleep
deprivation results in
increased risk-taking,
likely secondary to
suboptimal or abnormal
functioning of the
prefrontal cortex, nucleus
accumbens, and insula.
It results in more
rigid thinking,
perseveration of ideas, and
difficulty in incorporating
new information.
And here's the worst
news. It's likely that
coffee or other
caffeinated beverages can't
stop one who is sleep
deprived from poor
performance, secondary
to cognitive deficits,
making poor decisions
and taking undue risks.
Have you ever
spent more than 24
hours awake and then
two or three days
later had a cold
or a sore throat?
Well, it turns out
that if we don't
get enough sleep,
we are three times
more likely to get
a cold. At less than
five hours a night
chronically, we
are four times as
likely. In addition,
sleep deprivation
results in decreased
antibody responses
to vaccines
and increases the
risk of pneumonia.
The truth is, if you
don't take care of
yourself, you really
can't take care of others.
In summary, normal
sleep physiology is
dictated by circadian
rhythms that
orchestrate hormonal and
physiologic functions
that maintain
normal homeostasis.
stasis. Sleep disorders
are prevalent and
many can be diagnosed
by a primary provider
with sleep studies,
while some require
outside consultation
for management.
Sleep is an integral
part of physician
wellness that optimizes
safety and care of the
patient. And please
give us feedback on this
lecture. We really do
value your opinion.
Thank you. Good
luck and stay well.